je n'arrête pas de dire j'en ai rien à
de cannes à mon producteur depuis
le début quand j'étais en train de
monter judy je m'en fous de cannes ne
fait pas un film pour cannes est
aujourd'hui mais je suis contente d'être
là parce que c'est aussi notre place à
nous qu'à nous appartient qu un etat
nous aussi mais rien j'en ai encore on
est là c'est possible que ce soit une
pointe qui nous est remis le prix
quoique c'est si juste une tuerie quoi
c'est une tuerie que ça soit une femme
et pour que les choses changent il faut
mettre beaucoup plus de gens non
décisionnaire ça des femmes beaucoup
plus de femmes aiment dans les
sélectionneurs aujourd'hui tout l'excès
avec son ton
on devrait dire merci merci à qui elle
attrape je vais le dire pas du